la joie démonstrative du coup nous bénit
a enchanté le dernier festival de cannes
la palme d'or c'est bien de theo
angelopoulos qu'il a reçu son bonheur
immense était plus intérieure je vous
remercie tous
l'éternité et un jour est à l'image de
son réalisateur grave et sensible car
quand je passe entre rêve et réalité
souvenir est présent l'histoire d'un
écrivain à la recherche du temps perdu
alexandre malade vit sa dernière journée
ce film testament lumineuse pour une
simple question est ce qu'on fait si on
a seulement un joueur given
qu'est ce qu'on fait
donc c'est filmé sous l'aviez pas soldat
mort l'écrivain célèbre interprété par
bruno ganz croyait tout savoir mais
c'est un gosse des rues qui lui
apprendra l'essentiel
le petit clandestin d'exil le vieil
homme et la mort deux personnages en
fuite face à l'inconnu
si oui vous restez un jour à vivre
qu'est ce que vous feriez ce jour là je
ne sais pas a peut-être un film avec
celui ci onzième film en 28 ans le
réalisateur grec est au sommet de son
art dans ce poème bouleversant il y à du
bergman et du visconti
avant de partir alexandre l'écrivain se
souvient de ce qu'il a oublié d mais
cela valait bien une palme est un peu
d'éternité